okay matthew if you were to choose any
song for your character to sing which
song would you choose
in scene two
any any sing three which is gonna happen
three scene three would you rather have
grape nuts or go nuts that was a song
title that was brought up to me it's
possibly in scene 3 and um i don't know
what it all means but i hope it's go
nuts instead of grape nuts because
i'm i'm not drinking milk these days oh
fun fact fun fact garth said he'd want
you to do uh a folk song by the fire but
he said you would probably choose disco
i wouldn't be afraid of disco but i tell
you what fo
give me some dylan
give me some credence so i can lean in
yeah my dream is to see you do hey yeah
by outcast just so you can do that all
right all right all right all right yes
they do do great all right that's my
dream there's a lot of all right all
right all right in
tunes yeah in the past and they pop up
in places and i hear them and i'm like i
didn't steal them from them or did i but
they were around before i threw that
line out oh
fun fact another one that's two for the
day
so there is a poll where people
are really fond of the idea of you
running for governor of texas
are you still into that idea no i
released a statement just the other day
saying i'm not going to run this is not
the right time for me right now gave us
some serious consideration over the last
couple of years
well as a privileged
mindset to be in to think about what if
yeah would i be right for that job why
but right now it's not it's not the move
for me it's not the not where i can be
most useful yeah hollywood reporter said
philanthropist of the year that is your
honor you know what does something like
that mean to you
that was really cool to get that call
yeah they said hey we want to shine on a
light on the work that you and your team
have done
over the past year you know my wife and
i've had that just keep living
foundation for 12 years now
and then particularly last year there
was a big freeze in texas and uh a lot
of people were out at home and needed
help and
you know so much you get reminded you
think these things are someone's there
to handle them yeah and you're reminded
well why not you right now everyone all
hands on deck and we reached out to
everybody we reached out to immediately
was like i'm in how can i help and we
put that together in like two weeks
and raised over seven point seven
million dollars to help out texans that
were affected by the freeze
and the challenge with when these the
natural disaster comes is you better
move quick because something else is
gonna steal the headline there's
something else that's going to be needed
to help out with
coming on the front page of the news any
day now so you need to do it in a timely
fashion and we had a lot of help a lot
of people stepped up so it was nice to
have a light shined on them as well yeah
when you're
when your kids are watching this movie
are you hoping that they like your
character the most
i
i
i know i'm well enough now
to know that i'm probably not gonna be
their favorite character they like
buster moon
they might
like him even more
if well would they like it more if it
wasn't that no they think it's cool that
that their papaya their dad's buster
moon but their favorites always
some very
small sub character like the little
robots that are the the cleaners that
hop up and do the tap that's their
favorite thing
i love them okay yeah um they love the
uh um what's the character the
the blonde mane who goes in
the romantic league oh okay they they
they love that character um of course
they love gunther i love going through
terms
i'm fine how are you i'm a big fan
cracks me up every time i hear them um
but they always love little sub
characters and all in all movies even
live action they always love little sub
characters i'm usually not their
favorite character dms all right well
thank you
you